l'albatros va rouvrir ses portes au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
parcours qui accueille tous les ans
l'open de france a été totalement
relooké en vue de la ryder cup 2018 130
personnes ont travaillé sur cette
rénovation pendant neuf mois c'était
problème un délai de la pelouse
challenge coordonnées tout se perd sont
tous été repris ces dames entre
guillemets une petit espace commencé et
pour essayer d'aider de retenir la la la
la meilleure efficacité pour le chantier
les clients n'ont pas pu accéder au
green c'est réouverture était donc
attendue depuis plusieurs semaines
quand le volet l'albatros est oui oui il
ya et nos clients sont arrivés reyel
albâtre et c'est pas cool ces nouvelles
versions des départs ou les principaux
changements de cet albatros 2.0 concerne
les trous numéro 11 et 16
les deux parcours ont été totalement
remodelé pour les rendre plus esthétique
pour le 11 un lac a été créé des
difficultés ont également été modifiées
mois pour les tonnelles et trouve
quelqu'un pour les joueurs amateurs
ça va être plus simple est vraiment
hé hé
et ça va on m'a samus et ça va plus ça
nous semble on a fait les soldes
s'approche et que ça va être moins
compliquée pour les joueurs amateurs et
aimé par contrat par les duels
professionnel et il y a
il ya pas mal de sauce tacle qui vont
qui vont faire la tâche est difficile en
2018 de l'open de france pour fêter
cette réouverture le golf national
organise un concours de précision ce
samedi 30 avril de 11h à 18h sur le trou
numéro 11